don bluth's 1986 animated film an
american tale tells the story of a young
jewish russian immigrant
fievel mouskowitz who is separated from
his family during their journey to
america while fleeing the tsar's cossack
pogroms in 1885.
the film explores corrosive and false
mid-century reactionary versions of the
american myth that painted late 19th
century america as gladly welcoming all
immigrants
these revisionist myths largely
propagated throughout the 1950s 60s and
70s
in an attempt at bulwarking coalitions
of italian polish and irish-americans
ethnic groups that were routinely
considered non-white prior to world war
ii against the gains of black americans
in the civil rights movement
the newly bowdlerized version of
american history played up the
contemporary
positives of the period essentially
taking emma lazarus's sonnet the new
colossus
give me your tired your poor your
huddled masses yearning to breathe free
and treating it as the popular consensus
of late 19th century america
and not an equally radical statement
then
as it is now opposed as it was by a
substantial nativist movement
an american tale plays with these
revisionist myths by having the irish
jewish and sicilian immigrant mice
repeat the myth on the boat ride from
europe there are no cats in america
and the streets are paved with cheese
cats being synecdoche for racism
exploitation and the predator class as a
whole within the movie's metaphor
however when the immigrant mice arrive
in america they discover that not only
are there cats in america america is
full to the tits with cats
the mid-century myth is contrasted with
the reality that
immigrants arrived to america to
discover the predator class
intact ready to enforce societal
stratification along racial
and ethnic lines by whatever means
necessary
in this regard an american tale is
simply repeating the same lesson learned
in dick whittington and his cat
when it was london's streets that were
said to be paved with gold
sir whittington arriving in london to
find not gold literal or metaphorical
but grime poverty and cholera however
an american tale fumbles its metaphor at
the end while the climax of the film
where the cats are driven into the sea
in an allusion to the biblical demon
legion can be seen as
aspirational or instructive it is more
likely to be read
as its own form of revisionism though an
american tale suggests that the predator
class was a reality of american life
confronting one form of revisionism the
emphasis
is on was suggesting it is one of the
past
a demon driven into the ocean a century
earlier
[Applause]
[Music]
in succumbing to the necessity of a
happy ending an american tale succumbs
as well to white
post-racial fantasies common following
the passing of the civil rights act
still while the ending of the film may
be overly simplistic
an american tale is unique among
children's media for its willingness to
depict the crowding squalor
exploitation and abuse that immigrants
faced
the film even includes commentary on the
internal racial aggression of the
underclass via the use of names
in how fievel's ally tony a second or
third generation italian immigrant
himself
all but refuses to use fivel's given
name
preferentially calling him philly
that name's got a goal hey i'll tell you
what
philly an actor that recreates the
structural suppression of culture
seen when the mousekowitz's arrive at
immigration and tanya's name is changed
to tilly by the immigration clerk
okay mr smith
[Music]
aside from these thematic elements the
film itself is a bit of a drag
despite its short run time around the
midpoint of the film the story grinds to
a halt and fievel spends an
inordinate amount of time fuzzing around
with the vegetarian cat tiger
while tiger as an idea reflects the
thematic beat that it's not species that
defines evil but
behavior tiger being a member of the
predator class with no
instinct for predation his role in the
film is largely to
consume time with the comedy stylings of
dom deluise
do you really think so on the whole
though as with much of don bluth's work
in the 1980s
an american tale is a flawed but unique
and
valuable piece of children's media
confronting a young audience with
difficult
often complex ideas emotions and
realities
and 21 years later it was made into one
of the worst video games ever
[Music]
developed by data design interactive and
published by blast entertainment an
american tale was released for the
playstation 2 in 2007
and it is one of the worst retail games
i have ever encountered
fivel mousekowitz returns six huge
missions
steer fievel inside a bubble hitch a
ride on the back of a pigeon and escape
from the cats aboard a roller skate
four bonus levels relive the movie
see the thrilling story unfold through
classic clips from the animated movie
let's get started before these six huge
missions and fort bonus levels commence
we're treated to the menu where a
dead-eyed digital simulacrum of five
mouse quit stands
as a grim important of things to come
entering a new game we get a short clip
from the opening of the film
fievel running from the cossack cat and
the family boarding the ship that will
take them across the atlantic to america
how then will they translate this into a
game
it's super monkey ball it's it's super
monkey ball
on a pirate ship fievel is in a soap
bubble
and it's super monkey ball on a pirate
ship
21 years after the movie went to
theaters some dudes turned it into a
video game
and it's super monkey ball on a pirate
ship there's not really a blow-by-blow
to be had
because there's just not that much to
the level there's only two rooms
neither is very complex they're just
prolonged by the atrocious controls
making it simultaneously insultingly
easy
and comically difficult after reaching
the cheese in the second room the player
gets another short movie clip and fievel
gets to move his soap bubble onwards to
the first bonus level which is
just more super monkey ball this is
actually optional anyway you can
just skip it from the menu but if you do
decide to try and complete it because
you hate yourself
buckle up because it is both far more
difficult and complex than the previous
level
fievel needs to collect three cheeses
that are scattered around a huge puzzle
room
and in the process of getting them
you'll get to enjoy such thrilling
moments as
thing you can't see that knocks you off
swinging barrels that utterly ruin the
camera controls
a weird push maze that you need to
reassemble after decoding the bizarre
visual instructions ever-present wind
and boat noises
and falling into the water over and over
and over and over and over again
i can't overstate just how awful these
barrels are
like you can't you just you can't you
you can't
just come on just you just
i get the feeling that they were just
working on levels in a linear order and
then realized that the second level was
impossible for their target demographic
so rather than
change anything they just called it a
bonus level and made it skippable
in fact on that note all the other bonus
levels are not just
easier than this one they are
substantially easier than
everything else in the game the second
proper level is a flight sim
where fievel rides on the back of ari
the pigeon and the player must navigate
the two of them through the busy new
york harbor until fivel
is safely delivered to the cheese
floating over a pirate ship
well it sounds easy enough but here's
the catch henry has a stamina bar
that depletes comically fast so every
few seconds the player
needs to fly through floating bird seed
to refill the stamina bar
colliding with water geese or any
obstacles will also take off a huge
chunk of stamina
there's actually several stretches where
bird seed restores less stamina than it
takes to fly between them
meaning that in addition to the obvious
reactive challenges of the level
there's also the strategic challenge in
that you're simultaneously fighting
entropy
henry controls so poorly that it's
impossible to get all the seed and the
seed you can get
is barely enough to get through to the
end of the level and don't go thinking
that if you miss some seed you can just
loop back and get it
even trying is going to consume far more
stamina than you'll get
so you're just dooming yourself to a
slow loss even
if you fly the rest of the level
perfectly and if you hit something
you're pretty much
done not only is the stamina cost just
as much of a slow death as poor flying
there's a pretty good chance that you'll
just get stuck to
or inside of whatever you hit
and i should point out that you don't
really steer per se
there's an ever-present lag between
input and reaction so for the most part
you're not steering as much as you're
gently tapping the d-pad to make micro
corrections to your course
the cherry on top of all that is that
the level is so poorly designed and the
engine
so poorly optimized the gameplay
actually slows down
and gets less responsive as more
and more assets are loaded so not only
is the path
getting harder with narrower passages
and tighter turns
the fundamental interaction is getting
more
and more difficult as the game chugs to
a crawl
and inputs take longer and longer
to register and the whole time the whole
time
you've got this music
is this music i mean yes technically
because the game was made as cheaply as
possible none of the music from the film
was licensed
so rather than having the film score or
any of the original songs or even sound
alikes
the levels are all populated with
bizarre tonally inappropriate
royalty-free pop jazz music
it gets old really fast
assuming you managed to eventually get
to the cheese on the pirate ship the
next bonus level consists of fievel
floating down between laundry like that
one small moment in the movie
this is a bit more of what i would
expect from a game made for six year
olds
it's short and pretty easy but you can
still fail
so you need to at least try but after
the previous level
i'm not sure any six year old is ever
getting here anyway if you want the pro
strats for this absurdly easy minigame
you can use circle and x to break or
speed up
and i highly recommend you press x to
get this over with
as fast as possible for level 3 fievel
is stuck in the street and needs to
collect 16 cheeses to advance while
dodging humans and horses
the hardest part of this level is
fighting against the camera angle
it's so close to the ground that the
open manholes are basically invisible
and it's now impossible to accurately
gauge
depth like here i feel
like i should be on this cheese but i'm
not
i'm still in front of it anyway it's
still not difficult
the next bonus level is just more
falling except now it's at night
between levels we get one more short
movie clip that provides no story
context whatsoever
but it's kind irrelevant because we're
about to head into a sewer
level 4 is actually level 4-1
see both this level and the next one
take place in the sewers but
rather than just calling them levels 4
and 5 someone decided they should be
called
4-1 and 4-2 so that the final level
would be five but the back of the box
says six levels because even if you
hyphenate
two of them they're still distinct
levels so why not just call them
four and five this game is a glimpse
into madness
so for level 4-1 fievel needs to ghost
behind warren t-rat's accountant digit
it's the exact same idea as the stocking
missions in assassin's creed
a game that incidentally came out a few
months before this one
except you know bad
the added user interface objects showing
if you're too close or too
far somehow managed to look out of place
in a game where nothing
actually looks like belongs just like
almost everything else in the game it's
not actually very hard but
the unresponsive controls and frequent
abrupt failures make it feel
far more difficult than it really is if
you do decide to try this game out i'll
save you a lot of headache and let you
know that fievel has a double jump
that's critical to beating the level
there's obstacles that are impossible to
clear without it also
don't waste time trying to balance on
pipes fievel is just going to fall off
you can get past just about every
barrier by running up the slope of the
wall and then jumping over it
once you make it to the cheese at the
end of the level it's on to the bonus
level which is
more falling just in a sewer to be fair
this bonus level does escalate the
difficulty from the previous levels with
the addition of moving spikes and pipes
that spray poison gas
you actually need to use the brakes and
acceleration strategically to avoid
damage
but there's also a lot of bonus health
available so it's still pretty forgiving
again these bonus levels are the only
part that really feels
age appropriate to the target market now
level 4-2
honestly after the flying level where
the game slowly
chokes and dies on its own assets i
didn't think the game had any more
surprises for me
i mean how could it top that well
how about a physics-based downhill racer
that controls about as well as an actual
mouse
riding a roller skate down a sewer pipe
just like honoree the roller skate devil
rides is so temperamental that you're
not steering as much as you're just
gently nudging as a suggestion of where
to go
even being really light on the controls
it's still super
easy to skid out and jack knife the
roller skate
oh and a bizarre detail that's not super
obvious from the footage
but the directional controls are
oriented to
the pipe not the skate so once the skate
turns
more than 90 degrees sideways the
controls flip
left becomes right and right becomes
left but as you try to turn back around
they flip again once you're mostly
facing forwards
making it super easy to just get stuck
sideways and stall out
also there's no accelerator fievel has
no way of gaining velocity
except rolling down a hill so if the
skate glances off a pipe and loses
momentum
it's entirely possible to get stuck in a
position where the skate just
rolls back and forth between two small
lumps in the terrain that it
can't quite get over until the cats
catch up to field and you fail back to
the start of the level
should you escape warranty rat and make
it to the cheese it's on to the sixth
and final level level five an auto
scroller where the player steers the
mouse of minsk
and chases the cats off the pier and i
have to say
i do not use that word lightly the mouse
of minsk may not steer well
but compared to henri and the roller
skate it does
steer so if you avoid enough boxes and
don't tip over or fall in the water
what do you get congratulations fievel
has saved new york from the cats and
been reunited with his family
maybe finally they can settle down and
enjoy their new life
in america roll credits
that's it not even a movie clip there
are in total
87 seconds of the actual film in the
game
see the thrilling story unfold through
classic
clips from the animated movie now
many of you connoisseurs of bad video
games
you may be wondering why nay how you
have never heard of this before
and it's because this game is
surprisingly rare
it was only released in europe australia
and new zealand as a budget title for
the playstation 2 at a time when
retailers were quickly pivoting to the
newly released playstation 3 and xbox
360.
so it wasn't exactly a massive
distribution in the first place
and it's only available in pal video
format so it's not
impossible to find but it's hardly
cluttering up pawn shops like
sports titles of years past it was
actually a bit of an ordeal for me to
get a working copy
just to add to the cheapness the game is
printed on cds not
dvds which would explain why there's
only a whopping 87 seconds of movie
footage in the game
now being cd based wasn't super uncommon
for playstation 2 games but they're
somewhat notorious for not working
properly
and this was the problem i was having my
pal playstation would read dvd-based
games just fine
but not an american tale which was the
only cd-based game i had available
now just to explain this when playing a
cd-based game the playstation 2 needs to
adjust the focal distance of its laser
and run the disc drive's motor at a much
higher rpm than what is used for dvd
games
as a result the two most common points
of failure are that the cd setting for
the laser falls out of position
or the disc spins too fast and slips
inside the disc tray because the stopper
doesn't have a tight enough grip
a commonly recommended solution for disk
slipping is what's called
the tape trick the idea is to put a few
short strips of tape on the top of the
disc giving the stopper extra grip
so i tried this since it's a pretty
simple home hack
and something went wrong the tape got
caught inside the drive though it
didn't damage the playstation at all and
when i took the game out of the tray the
tape had actually peeled off the label
and the reflective aluminum layer
underneath
because the game is printed on super
cheap cds where the label
is screen printed directly onto the back
of the reflective layer
with no protective plastic or lacquer
backing in between
this isn't unheard of it's just the
video game equivalent of a pulp novel
printed on low quality paper and
bound with cheap glue that dries out and
cracks so the game is uncommon it's
region locked and it's fragile
and i have two copies now whatever one
of them works
so why
why part one why does this exist
the simple answer is money i wish there
were a deeper story here but that's
really it
the game is exactly what it looks like a
cheaply made product
shoveled out at a budget price using a
recognizable franchise
to draw at least a modicum of attention
blast entertainment was a london-based
publisher and development studio focused
on cheaply made budget games
usually leveraging an older less popular
or forgotten movie license
like water horse legend of the deep
charlotte's web
lassie dr doodle home alone babe beverly
hills cop
jumanji xena warrior princess and top
gun
most of these games coming out years or
decades after
their respective properties data design
interactive
similarly was a shovelware developer
though licensed games were more the
exception than the rule in their library
like you maybe remember them for ninja
bread man
but probably not according to producer
stuart green's linkedin page
data design interactive was the leading
publisher of nintendo wii titles
with 28 titles developed and published
in a single year
well he doesn't say what year that was
and i have no easy means to verify that
information
i'm going to take him at his word
because why would you brag about that
the other producer mark gemmell
currently works for pickpock making
microtransaction stuff cow clicker games
now why part 2
why care i wanted to share this with you
not because it's important or
good or an underrated gem but because
it's none of those things
this game is bad it's cheaply made it's
difficult to find it's largely forgotten
it's not fun and for all those reasons
it's likely to vanish entirely
and that's why i wanted to preserve it i
believe in the value of failed art
art that is driven by carelessness by
unchecked and untalented ego
by spectacularly low stakes greed it has
a tendency to be novel to be
unpredictable in a way that deliberate
art
never can this is why it's so much fun
to watch
bad movies no one would ever make this
game on purpose something in the
creative process
needs to be fundamentally broken to get
to this point
if you were going to sit down two
decades later to make a game
out of an american tale because you
actually cared about the movie and you
cared about making a game you're not
going to churn out a hodgepodge series
of disconnected mini games that
don't work well it is not simply a lack
of time
or money that produces something like an
american tail to video game
but a profound lack of caring
the end product of that broken process
isn't worth playing for its own merits
but it is worth playing because it's
worth remembering
so thank you all for coming along
i hope you all have shared in my epic
erica see
the joy of looking on something
[Music]
bad
you